hello everyone and thank you for
attending
today i'm going to talk about continuous
tasks and the asynchronous computability
theorem
this is a joint work with sergio raxbaum
and ulrich schmidt
so
this is the oh the overview of what i'm
going to talk today first
i'm going to talk a bit about
distributed systems then a bit about
topology and also about the topological
modeling of distributed systems
and then i'm going to go over our
contributions in in our paper
i will talk about continuous task a
chromatic version of the simplicial
approximation theorem
and also a complete characterization of
weight-free continuous touch solvability
and extensions to density requirements
so
we are interested in distributed stems
from an abstract point of view and we
consider only finite set of processes
which can communicate using shared
memory
and their failure model is
crashes failure model and
we are interested in asynchronous
systems
and also we are interested in some tasks
tasks such as consensus and approximate
agreement
so i will talk now a bit about the
communication so in a shared memory
model
processes uses a common memory object to
communicate
and we use a convenient abstraction we
use the iterated immediate snapshot
model for this which means that
each process has its own individual
memory section in which they write
but they can read the whole memory
object
so the synchrony model is an
asynchronous
model in which each process runs at it
as at its own speed
and computation is organized in logical
rounds and rounds happen at different
real times and each process has it has
its own
clock and each process works at it at
its own speed
and we are interested also in great
freedom which means that
since up to n-1 processes are allowed to
crash then each process must be able to
make progress and work independently of
other process
so
what is a distributed task well
if to define a distributed task we need
a set of valid inputs a set of valid
outputs and a validity condition that
matches
valid inputs to valid outputs and we
also need terminating condition
this means
when is
the right moment when when a process can
make a decision and stop its execution
so to put into contrast a
sequential problems
with distributed tasks in sequential
problems we are usually interested in
computing functions and usually you have
a single input and a single output and
the computability is determined by the
processing capabilities
and we are interested in analyzing the
algorithmic complexity while in
distributed tasks
the problem is to coordinate processes
to compute outputs
and the computability is limited by the
communication and failure assumptions
and we are interested in the round and
message complexity
of distributed tasks
and
we in particular were interested in
agreement tasks agreement tasks are
tasks
where processes are given input values
and they must
communicate to agree
on some output
so for example we could be interested
that these outposts outputs
are not too large so for example in
consensus we are interested that they
decide on a single
input value or or on k-set agreement
where we are interested that they decide
on at most k different
values
or we could also be interested in
approximate agreement where the outputs
must be sufficiently close or even
we could be interested that the output
outputs are different such as renaming
and symmetry breaking
so why do we
want to study agreement tasks well
because they have several practical
applications such as a
blockchain
and
also
databases and and so and also because
agreement tasks are useful benchmarks
for studying how strong is a distributed
computing model
and we want to study agreement tasks
to determine their solvability and we
want to design efficient protocols for
these tasks
so now i will go up into topology so
topology is all about spaces continuous
functions and
in particular we are interested in
connectivity
we are not interested in
general topology we are
going to be more interested in
combinatorial topology
and the idea is to con construct spaces
from a combinatorial definition
so i will start with simplicity
simplices are
a multi-dimensional triangles
which are defined by a set of vertices
finite set of vertices and
a phase of a simplex is simply any
subset of vertices
and we can use these
simplices and glue them together along
common borders to form
more elaborate structures which are
called simplicial complexes
so here we see the formal definition of
an abstract simplicial complex
which is a combinatorial construction
and it's not a
in principle is not tied to the idiom to
a geometric interpretation
we start with a vertex set and we also
have a phase set and this is enough for
defining an abstract simplicial complex
and
as with all
mathematical objects we also have
functions and
in this case the functions are called
simplicial maps simplicial map is simply
a vertex map that preserves the
structure it means that
it's it is a function that maps faces to
faces and it is called chromatic if it
also preserves some color structure
and a
simplicial complexes can also be endowed
with a geometric interpretation and this
is very easy to use we simply use a
finely generated spaces to have this
geometric interpretation
and we will use a
the parse notation to refer to geometric
realization of simplicial complex
so for example a
on the left side we have an octahedron
which is a simplicial complex an
abstract simplicial complex
and on the right side we have a sphere
and
this we can think of a sphere as a
geometric realization of this octahedra
another
important thing to talk about is a
subdivision subdivision is an essential
operation on simplicial complexes and
basically what it does is that it
refines
simplicial complexes into smaller
phases so for example here on the left
we have a simplicial complex on the
middle we have
a body-centric subdivision and on the
right we have a chromatic subdivision of
asymptotical complex
so
an interesting thing is that when we
have a geometric realization of a
simplicial map then
this geometric realization is a
continuous function and we want to know
if the reciprocal is true also
that it
what does it mean
that if we have a continuous function
between geometric spaces
it does this gives us a simplicial map
that is sufficiently similar to the
function
and the answer is yes
and it's called the simplicial
approximation theorem
which basically tells us that if we have
a continuous function between two
spaces then
there is a body-centric subdivision of
some some simplicial complex
that allows us and the simplicial map
that behaves very similar to the
function so we can look at this figure
and
for example the
red curve
is a simplicial approximation to the
blue curve
so
now i will talk about the topological
modeling so what is the main idea well
the main idea is to construct a
simplicial complex from the from the
model
and
we want to do this because then this
helps us express non-trivial features as
topological properties
for example agreement tasks are
closely related to
k-dimensional holes
and the way that we do this is
we take a local states to define
vertices and we take global states and
these define
the maximal phases or facets
of a simplicial complex
and the indistinguishability of the
system tells us how they intersect how
the faces intersect and how they are
adjacent to each other
so for example we take the two process
weight free shield memory case
in this example we have two processes a
green process and a red process
so because the processes are weight free
and asynchronous
what could happen is these three
possibilities either the green process
is faster and is able to finish before
the red process
learns its input value or
either the red process is faster or
both are sufficiently close with each
other's speed and they are able to learn
each other inputs and
as you can see in this case where both
processes have similar speeds then
it is indistinguishable both for the
green process and for the red process
whether or not
the other process was able to learn
their inputs
so
here is the formal definition of an
input complex
for defining an input complex
we simply take the
process ids and the input values and
this gives us the
vertex set
and for the faces we use the input
configurations which make these edges
for example
this is an input complex for a binary to
process task
and for output complex is essentially
the same but we are more interested
about
outputs rather than inputs and in this
example we have
the output complex
of of a
consensus task binary
to process consensus
and we also need to talk about carrier
maps and validity so a carrier map is a
function that maps
a
simplex into a into a soft complex so
for example in this figure weak map
this upper lid of the octahedron is
mapped to only this yellow leaf
this
lower lead of this ectahedron is mapped
to the lower lead of the output complex
however the intermediate faces which are
shaded in blue
can
are allowed to decide either the upper
leaf or the lower lid
and this is all we need to represent a
binary three process consensus
so now that we have
a
specified tasks
with a combinatorial topological model
then we are
ready to
define what is a protocol complex so the
idea is that we want to capture the
evolution of a distributed system
and to do that we
have a sequence of protocol complexes p0
p1 all
up to pk
one per round in which they input
complex p0
and
the idea is the same that vertices of a
protocol are local views
and the faces are the global states of
the system
and the communication
operation transforms a protocol complex
into the next stage of a protocol
complex
in particular in the weight-free shared
memory modeling in which we are
interested
each communication rounds
really is a chromatic subdivision
so
this is an example of the weight-free
shared memory model
vote for three processes at time zero at
round zero where no process has
communicated with anyone
each process is only aware of their own
input value
but after one round of communication
there are all of these possibilities
of course it could happen that the
blue process was very fast and it was
able to finish its communication route
without learning any of the inputs from
the other processes
however it could also happen for example
that
the red process
that is
that has this view
it could
be
not so fast as a blue process
and both was able to learn the the input
value from the blue process but it was
not able to learn the input value from
the green process
and this is represented by this view
here the red process knows the
blue input value the red input value but
it doesn't know the green input value
and if we want to compute
for the
a protocol complex we simply take
each any
each of these triangles and we subdivide
it once more
so now
this can be captured perfectly by the
formulation of the asynchronous
computability theorem
which is due to helihe and chaby
which basically says that a distributed
task is solvable in weight free
asynchronous shared memory
if and only if there is a
chromatic subdivision and a sim
chromatic simplicial map
that is preserved by the
carrier map
of the validity decision
so
here is one example of
a of of an application of this theorem
here we can see that binary three
process consensus is not solvable in the
weight-free shared memory and the reason
why this happens is because as we have
shown before
the communication in the weight free
shared memory only subdivides the input
complex
which means that it doesn't matter how
many runs of communication we have this
input complex will always be
homeomorphic to the sphere which is
connected
and if we have any decision map
since decision since since a simplicial
map is induces a continuous function
and
the input complex is connected then we
cannot
use a continuous function to disconnect
the input complex
which would be required by the consensus
task specification
so
now we can talk about our contributions
so
the asynchronous computability theorem
allows us to match
that solvability to simplicial maps
and at the same time
the simplicial approximation theorem
matches continuous function to
subdivisions
another question is can we directly
match test solvability to continuous
functions
and the answer is yes
but the continuity is not enough
so
let me talk you about the following task
which is the hourglass task which is
simply we want to
map this input complex into this output
complex
and
the
borders should be mapped to the borders
which means that this
red border should be mapped to this red
border and then these other borders
should be mapped to this other border
and the lower border should be mapped to
the lower border and that's it
so there actually is a simplicial map
that solves the hourglass task
we simply
map the borders as
stated accordingly and we
map all these
yellow
colored vertices we map them into these
yellow colored vertex in the middle
and that's it
there actually it's a simplistic map
that preserves
the validity conditions
but
actually we cannot solve the hourglass
task in a synchronous shared memory
and the reason is really simple it's
because if we could solve the hourglass
task we could also solve to set
agreement
and we know that to set agreement is
impossible in the synchronous shared
memory
so what is wrong well
the answer is quite simple the
simplicial map doesn't preserve the
color structure and
any simplicial map that stops the
hourglass
task will
forcibly collapse part of the simplicial
complex
so
in order to address these
problems and to
elaborate appropriate conditions that
allow us to specify which functions can
can
be
can solve
these tasks um
we need to add an extended coloring and
a simplicial neighborhood definition
which are
these
which basically the extended coloring is
is allows us to
choose a color set for for a point and
the simplicial neighborhood is simply
a
any interior
set that is homeomorphic to a simplex
so for example this yellow triangle is a
two-dimensional simplicial neighborhood
and the red segment is a one-dimensional
simplicial neighborhood
so a
now that we have those definitions then
we can say that a
chromatic function is a continuous
function
and that it
has this property with respect to the
colors
which means that the colors that
the
image and that the image and the pre
image have in common should be at least
the same as as the amount of generators
that it needs
so for example this function is not
chromatic because it collapses
this red segment into a single point
so
and now we can talk about the chromatic
approximation theorem so
basically we we give a condition for
what is a chromatic approximation a
chromatic approximation is
essentially
[Music]
very similar to
the simplicial approximation but
we
require it to preserve the color
structure
and
the theorem is that any chromatic
function has a chromatic approximation
and one thing that is worth noticing is
that any
chromatic simplicial map induces a
chromatic function
so
i will now give a
brief visual sketch of the proof
basically what we need to do is to
subdivide
the input complex until all simplices a
fall inside of a star like is shown in
the in the picture star is simply
a
the collection of all faces that contain
one point
so for example in this case
this simplex falls inside
this yellow star
once we have this then we simply match
we look at the color of the center of
the star and we match
the corresponding color of the
of the simplex to the center of the star
so we match the yellow vertex to the
yellow vertex
next we remove
the co the color the vertices that are
the same color of the center of the star
both from the
input simplex and in the output complex
this allows us to
reduce the
dimension of both the input complex and
the output complex and we also need to
take a projection because
uh this function used to be a
three-time
two-dimensional a function and now it
should be reduced to a one
dimensional function
and a
we want to do this because then if we
reduce the the dimension then we can
apply induction and repeat
so here for example we subdivide again
until
everything falls inside of a star here
for example this
a simplex falls inside this red star
this also falls inside this red star
this falls inside this green star and so
on
and once we have a done this
to decreasing dimensions then
we recover our maps to
get a higher dimensional solution
and
in the end we we join all of the
subdivisions to get a global subdivision
and that gives us a solution that gives
us a chromatic
approximation
so a
we now can speak about continuous tasks
so
it's all about tasks in the weight-free
shared memory are exactly matched to
chromatic functions
and this is the reason why we can now
specify tasks with continuous chromatic
functions
so our chromatic approximation theorem
states that a distributed task is
solvable in the
weight-free shared memory if and only if
there is a
a
chromatic function
that is carried by such a
decision map
and one nice result is that all
continuous tasks are solvable in the
weight frequent memory model
so this really
tells us
what are the solvable tasks in weight
frequent memory
and
one extra application of this is
what we call the consensus preference
approximate agreement
so in the practical applications
consensus is not solvable and is not
viable so
what we do is that we use approximate
agreement
to solve many of these problems
and
in approximate agreement we think that a
better solution is one that
has a higher proportion of exact
agreement outcomes
and
one advantage is that we can use
chromatic functions
to specify exactly what is the
proportion of exact agreements that we
want and to limit the proportion of
non-exact agreements
and one bonus thing is that if we know
the input probability distribution then
we can also control
the output probability distribution and
this is shown by the following
example so here
only the blue these tiny blue portions
of the input
are sent to
non-exact agreement to this output where
it's
one-third
one and two-thirds
but a very large portion of of it is
sent to exact agreement so this red
section is sent
to exact agreement where both agree to
two-thirds or where to both agree to
one-third
and
the takeaway is that we can use
chromatic functions to define continuous
tasks and continuous tasks characterized
with free shared memory
which is very nice because now we can
say that a weight-free shared memory
solubility is
essentially topological and chromatic
and
also chromatic functions are the key to
chromatic simplicial approximation and
a bonus thing is that we can use them to
express output density requirements
and that is all thank you very much for
your attention
you